encuentre el volumen del cubo cuyas
aristas miden 8 x ye cuadrada aquí
tenemos un cubo y nos están diciendo que
sus aristas y en el cubo todas las
aristas tienen la misma longitud cada
una de ellas mide 8x y el cuadrado así
que la longitud de esta arista que
podemos llamar el ancho mide 8x y
cuadrada la longitud de esta arista que
podemos llamar la profundidad o el largo
sería de 8 x de cuadrada y finalmente la
altura esta lista que tenemos aquí
también mide 8x y cuadrada en un cubo
todas las aristas son iguales
ahora para calcular el volumen de
cualquier prisma rectangular multiplicas
estas dimensiones multiplicas el ancho
por la profundidad por la altura ahora
como dijimos en el cubo miden igual
puedes tomar esta dimensión y
multiplicarla por sí misma tres veces o
puedes elevarla a la tercera potencia
así es que el volumen del cubo lo
podemos calcular como 8 x
y cuadrada y podría multiplicar esto por
si mismo tres veces o lo que es lo mismo
lo elevamos a la tercera potencia y es
por eso que elevar a la tercera potencia
se dice elevada al cubo pues es como si
estuvieras calculando el volumen de un
cubo cuya dimensión es lo que estás
elevando a la tercera potencia y esto a
cuánto va a ser bueno cuando tomas un
producto y estás elevando eso una
potencia eso es lo mismo que le ves a la
potencia cada uno de los factores y
posteriormente realices el producto así
es que esto equivale a 8 al cubo por x
al cubo o x a la tercera potencia y eso
que multiplica a ye cuadrada elevada al
cubo o elevada a la tercera potencia y
esto cuánto nos da bueno 8 el cubo 8 por
8 64 y 64 por 8 vamos a verlo por aquí
64 por 8 8 por 4 32 llevamos 36 por 8 48
y 351 512 esto es igual a 512
por equis cúbica x cúbica y multiplicada
por ye cuadrada al cubo aquí vamos a
aplicar la regla del producto de los
exponentes esto va a ser y elevado a la
potencia dos por tres
oye a la sexta hemos concluido
encontramos que el volumen del cubo es
512 x cúbica ya la sexta